So we're going to keep going.
Started with law.
Spent a little bit of
time talking on ethics.
But then going to move on to privacy.
And privacy's something that we all
have some idea of what it is and
the fact that we want it.
It actually goes all the way
back to Justice Brandeis.
Famous thing about
the right to be left alone,
but we want to examine it in the context
of, again, the online world.
So how do we define
privacy in this context?
Privacy is obviously related
to information about us.
In this context it'll be information
related to what we do online, and
data that we have in the visible form.
So definition basically is
a user's ability to control.
So that's the key thing here, control.
How data pertaining to us or
our activities Can be collected.
Who can actually collect such data?
You do your things, you visit a website,
you send an email, you make
a phone call, whatever it takes,
but who can collect information
about these activities?
How can this information be used,
and can they,
the entity that collects it,
share it with somebody else?
Here are the company, agency, whatever.
So it really the focus is on our
ability to control all of these,
and that's what privacy is.
It's our ability to control information
about us and in this case we're going to
focus on information that is collected,
shared, used in the online world.